last session of the workshop it's kind
of a tradition in women in theory that
we try to have and in this session so
six years ago when we were at simon's uh
we actually had a field trip to uh
google on site so we enjoyed that
wonderful free meal and got a little bit
a little souvenir i think was a very
nice water butter i still have it but
this time because of coverage we decided
to invite
speakers over wagon ago i was going to
come here but unfortunately she uh
tested pogba
a few days ago but she's so nice that
she's doing a remote talk for us
um so garden heads the
market research algorithms in
google research
and like many of the speakers here she
was a student here and also a speaker
in the past so uh
welcome gargan
[Music]
thank you lisa i hope you guys can hear
me um
uh yeah hi everyone uh my name is gagan
agarwal uh thank you lisa for the
introduction i work as a researcher at
google
and thank you lisa talan shibangi for
inviting me to give this talk
i would have loved to join
you guys for
this talk in person but unfortunately
had a change of plans
but i'm still happy that i'm able to
give this talk remotely
and uh at any point in the talk please
feel free to stop me and ask questions
so today i'll be talking about auto
bidding
oops uh
sorry can you still see my slides
wow okay you can still see my slides
i do not know what's going on on my side
just give me a second
that's bizarre
okay i'm just gonna restart this it's
behaving a little funny on my side my
slides so i'm just gonna restart the
stitch here in a second
yeah okay i think that works
i put this one here
okay so let's hope we can move through
these lines so
um so
today i'm going to talk about auto
bidding and auctions uh this is based on
uh joint work with ashwin kumar badani
duru arun nik mehta andres
let's start with the motivation um when
you search for something on google you
see some ads
in addition to the search results for
example here we are again for the query
flowers and
all these ads are selected using an
auction can you answer
let's get into that
for a query here we have the query
running shoes
and we retrieve all the ads um that are
relevant for the query
key ads to show and also requires
uh if suppose just to simplify the
situation let's say we were only picking
a common auction that is used is called
the second price
can you hear me
reaction where we rank the ads based on
their bid
or typically bid times and
time some quality score
and
the
and the highest bidder
gets the item and the price they pay is
the second highest bid
right so that's what one at auction
looks like
oops i am getting paid
from lisa
oh we can't see the slide oops
um hold on let me just um
stop the share and
restart the [ __ ]
are you able to see the slides now yes
okay
not
sure
um
go back to my
[Music]
okay great uh thanks chipra i will start
from the first slide wonderful um
so
let's go over here yeah
so we can go back here okay uh so this
was my title slide and then um this was
just an example to show what the ads
look like on a search page and this is
the
auction view
uh
where um
okay
so this is the auction view where we ran
a query uh for the uh where we ran an
auction for the query um running shoes
and we picked four ads but in general
let's say for a simplified case let's
say you were running an auction for just
one position you would have run the
second price auction
um sold it to the highest bidder at the
second highest bid okay
so let's hope this works can you see the
next slide
unfortunately my zoom window is showing
me nothing at this point basically
no
i see
okay can you see the next slide now
great
okay so now let us look at this from the
viewpoint of an advertiser
uh the advertiser is not participating
in just a single auction it usually
submits a bid per click for a keyword
and participates on all the auctions uh
that are relevant for that keyword and
based on its keyword bid uh you know it
is assigned a rank and a price for every
auction that it participates in and
across all of these auctions it gets a
certain number a total number of
impressions clicks conversions costs and
so on right so that is its view that i
am participating in all of these
auctions and this is my total cost my
total clicks and so on
and
a bidder could have many different goals
across
this aggregate
right sometimes it is quasi linear it is
trying to maximize value minus cost but
sometimes it could be trying to maximize
something else and it might have some
constraints as well and this is where
auto bidding comes in
um so consider an advertiser that has a
high level goal that they are trying to
optimize and some constraints
that need to be satisfied for example
someone might want to maximize clicks
while keeping their total spend below
100
right or they might be trying to
maximize conversions as long as their
average cost per conversion is no more
than three dollars right
such advertisers can use auto bidding uh
where a bidding algorithm bids on their
behalf into the auction into each
auction
and that results in a certain number of
total clicks conversions impressions
cost etc and it's the job of the bidding
algorithm to maximize their objective
function while satisfying their
constraints
so this is the aggregate that they get
at the end
um so auto bidding is increasingly being
used in online advertising and many
major advertising platforms offer auto
bidding uh here are some examples of
automating products from google one
offers to maximize your clicks within a
certain budget or maximize conversions
within budget or one is
it maximizes conversions but here the
constraint
is
cost per conversion like an average cost
per conversion should be no more than a
specified amount and in addition there
could be a budget constraint
and so on right so these are real world
examples of products which offer this
um
so this brings us to the topic of this
talk right so the so the rise of auto
bidding has given rise to several new
research directions
and this is what we want to talk about
here
and note that many of these questions
are still open and an active area of
research and um
and
the we'll talk about uh some of these
challenges so the first challenge we'll
talk about is designing algorithms for
auto bidding
and we'll talk about equilibria when
all the bidders are using auto bidding
or many of the bidders are using auto
bidding whether it exists how good it is
and so on
and finally if we have time we'll also
talk about reserve prices how they
behave in the auto bidding
setting so we will begin with uh
algorithms for auto bidding
great
okay here we go um
so this is uh
the problem
so we'll break it down into two pieces
so we'll first talk about the
just the selection problem and then in
some sense we'll talk about the bidding
problem bidding into an auction problem
so first we'll consider the problem uh
without its game theoretic aspects we
won't consider the other bidders at all
so we'll assume that uh
we are showing only one ad per query and
we refer to each query as an item
uh we will assume that the item costs
are fixed and in practice uh as we'll
see later these item costs are actually
determined by the bids of the
other uh
other buyers
and
and we will assume
for the bidding algorithm development
that the bids of the other bidders are
fixed so that's how the costs of the
uh of each item is fixed and we'll
consider two problems uh first uh is the
problem of uh
maximizing conversions within budget b
um
and uh and the second is maximizing
conversions under the average cost
constraint so that's what we'll begin
with uh
so let's let's see the budget constraint
as you can imagine this is uh like a
knapsack problem right you have a
knapsack of size b which is the budget
and you have items who have some value
and have some cost and you're trying to
fill your knapsack with the
with the with the items which fit within
the budget
but which have the maximum value and in
this case you can do greedy selection
uh by
bank per buck
and that will be optimal as long as
you're willing to take the last item
fractionally right and in these settings
each item is typically very small
compared to
what the bidder is going to get in
aggregate so we don't worry about the
fact that the last item is fractional we
can take it we cannot take it it doesn't
really matter in practice so we won't
worry about the fractional uh the fact
that we picked the last item
fractionally
so um so so that's our algorithm we'll
just do greedy bang per buck for this
case right that's our selection
algorithm
now let's consider the tcpa constraint
in this case
instead of having a knapsack of size b
we have the same items but in this case
we are looking for an average cost
constraint
average cost per conversion
constraint that it should not exceed
some pre-specified amount tcpa
which is
specified by the advertiser
okay
and
in this case also actually the same
greedy bank per book algorithm works
for a slightly different reason and i
leave that as an exercise
um
so in both of these cases what we ended
up with was the following algorithm we
came up with we'll come up with some
threshold tau
and it will be optimal to take all items
whose cost per conversion is less than
tau
not take any items whose cost per
conversion is greater than tau um and uh
and as i said like there could be a few
items in this case one item whose cost
per conversion will be equal to tau
uh
for input and general position of course
and we won't we won't worry about these
items
okay
um so let's convert this into a bidding
formula now
um
so we so as we noted in the last slide
with item costs fixed
it is optimal to win the items whose
cost is less than
tau
times the conversions from the item
right because we wanted the cost per
conversion to be
less than tau which is the same thing
so now if a seller runs a second price
auction for each item and the others
bids are fixed then essentially each
item's cost is also fixed
and if we bid exactly this amount tau
times expected conversions for the item
then we'll win if you're if it's a
second price auction right we'll win
exactly the ones where
this
quantity exceeds the cost
and won't win anything else
and this is what we wanted so this
bidding formula in some sense this star
times expected conversions for item is a
bidding formula and this gives us
exactly the right selection of items
uh this works only if the auction is
truthful like second price auction if
the auction is not truthful in fact the
optimal bidding algorithm is not simple
and uh there is an incentive to bid
differently like bid less
for items where the second highest bid
is is low
um
okay so let's
go to the next slide
um
so we can so the here we talked about
two very specific constraints uh now
we're gonna generalize so we can get a
similar bidding algorithm for actually
more complex goals and constraints
many kinds of linear goals and linear
constraints
using duality theory
and we'll illustrate this technique by
considering a buyer who is trying to
again maximize conversion but has two
constraints now he has both the budget
constraint and the tcpa constraint
and uh we will write the bidder problem
as an integer program and then we'll
relax it which is the lp that we see on
the slide right now
uh
let me see if you can see my pointer can
you see my pointer
okay i
um
sorry i'm just not able to
ah i lost it
um
um can you guys see my slide still
oh
no oh my god i see
yeah the moment i touch my computer it
just
refuses it stops sharing
okay let me try this again share screen
window
and
this guy has also
[Music]
okay i hope you can see the slide now
and
can you see my slide now
yeah and can you see my pointer on the
slide
now
uh
there's a pointer okay not c pointer
cannot see pointer okay that's okay um
that's
we'll live with this okay uh so
okay great great wonderful um so here
basically we are seeing that we are
trying to maximize uh this this
conversions
uh so vi let's say is the conversions
via says how many conversions we get
from item i x i is whether you got the
item so here we're trying to maximize
the total conversions
p i let's say is the cost of my of item
i and x i is whether you got the item
again and so this is the total cost so
it's saying
maximize my value
keeping my total cost within budget and
this is saying that keeping my total
cost below some fixed constant t which
the
which the buyer has has specified times
the value so which is the same as saying
that my cost per conversion
average cost per conversion should be no
more than t so these are the two
constraints that we have written
and uh we can um so we can solve this
directly right and get
uh get our x size but these exercises
will be really hard to use because
typically you know we are not we have to
solve this
problem on like historical data and then
we have to use it in the future so first
of all there is not a one-to-one
correspondence between items that
arrived yesterday and items that are
going to arrive tomorrow secondly this
is a huge amount of information to
remember
right so we're going to try and do
something better so we're going to write
the dual of this
of this program and
and then solve this tool right and this
is actually going to give us something
that we can
get we can use in practice
so we can prove the following theorem
that relates the optimal primal and dual
solutions
uh so what we can show and this is the
this is extending work of agarwal uh
bank and yay in uh in our paper uh two
years ago and uh
and the and what we can show is that
uh let excise star be the optimal primal
solution and alpha star beta star be the
optimal um dual solution
in that case we can compute this
factor the scaling factor and
only if the scaling factor times v i is
greater than p i
uh
whenever this is greater than p i then
x i is 1 then we want to take in the
primal solution we want to take that
item
and if it is less than p i then
then we don't want to take the item this
has a very similar form to what we
discussed before right we had this tau
and we said that we'll take it below tau
when the cost per conversion is below
tau and otherwise we want to take it
and this
equally easily converts into a bidding
algorithm so we just bid this scaling
factor times vi on query i
and take the query um and in this case
we'll win the query whenever we need to
win it
and as mentioned before there are of
course the cases where this is these two
quantities are equal
but what we can show is that for
instances in general position that
happens for only two of the eyes for
this particular thing and again we won't
worry about it what the way you can
think about is that maybe the
constraints will get violated by the
cost of these two impressions like at
most by the cost of these impressions or
that you won't be optimal uh
by the value generated by these two
impressions
um
okay so uh so a similar technique works
for more general constraints uh where we
can write an lp like this i won't go
into the details here but we are trying
to maximize some value
and we have a cost constraint that says
total cost is less than some budget
plus something and then you can have
many such constraints right
um
and again we can take the dual and
relate the optimal dual and primal
solutions let's not look at the theorem
it's grayed out but it gives us a
similar bidding algorithm
and this works in the multi-slot
setting as well where each query doesn't
have just one position that we are
selling but multiple positions
um and this works
for a truthful auction and again if we
don't have a truthful option the bidding
algorithm is not simple
um i will um
stop here and uh see if there are any
questions
i cannot see anybody so you can
basically say something or
you know put in the chat that'll be
great
i should not try to do anything
oh man
are your speakers on yes my speakers are
on
um
[Music]
but you know i am seeing uh two
things and one of them says
is on mute i'm not sure the simon's
institute auditorium is not on mute i
think but the other one might be on you
um
and i'm kind of scared to go no
questions okay okay
continue then without hopefully losing
my slides connection
here we go
um okay
so
okay so the final question we ask for
bidding algorithms is whether uh you
know this bidding algorithm can be used
in practice
um so i we think that it is useful in
practice and uh i'll point out two nice
properties of this algorithm one is that
as i mentioned before we only need to
remember
uh in the primal solution right we need
to remember a lot of things here we
don't actually need to remember many
parameters we just have to remember this
one
scaling factor in slightly more
complicated situations it could be a few
parameters you might have to remember a
few parameters
and then we can use this in practice uh
and and then we can apply it basically
on a query by query basis
uh
and uh
the
oops i should
advance my slide yeah um and the second
thing is
in practice right another question we're
interested in is what do i need to know
about the future queries like
if because
usually you don't have a very good idea
of what is going to come in the future
you can try and predict it but it's not
going to be accurate so how
dependent is your solution on that
and uh
and from agavalvangan uh and yay
and devon etc what we can show is that
the if you obtain your alpha star and
beta star from solving a dual on a
random sample of impressions then that
works pretty well so if we have a sample
of queries which is
similarly
similarly distributed to
what we're going to see in the future
then we can use this um
then the solution that we get is pretty
good
all right how much um
i should know this
how much time do i have
[Music]
i'm gonna try and it's gonna show
me okay
um
i'm sorry this is
why does this thing stop as soon as i
reach the
zoom window it just stops moving
now
[Music]
i'm gonna get my slides back i realize
that they are probably off by now
um
so i go to the zoom window share screen
new window
this guy share
okay hopefully it's back now
here we go
and i can see the chat
no questions okay
i will go back here um okay so next we
will look at
equilibrium properties um
under auto bidding
um
so
so the question we ask
here is that what if all the bidders are
using auto bidding that is they all have
their individual goals and constraints
and they're using the bidding algorithm
to
um to to produce bits
so then the bits of one bidder depend on
the prices that it faces which in turn
depends on the bids
um of the other of the other auto
bidders right uh so the bidders they
keep responding to each other's bids
until they settle into an equilibrium
um just to recall an equilibrium is a
setting of bids such that no bidder can
improve their utility by unilaterally
changing their bid
so the first question is is there an
equilibrium and the answer is yes under
some smoothness conditions
uh i won't go into the proof here
so the next question is how efficient is
this equilibrium and can we bound the
pro the price of anarchy
to answer these questions we actually
need to examine the definition of
welfare because it the definition of
welfare that we use in the standard
setting may not be applicable here so
we'll do that in the
sorry
in the next slide here we go
[Music]
um yeah so for quasi-linear agents the
way we define welfare is
um
is the
is the total is the sum over uh the
uh
the value that every agent receives
right so the sum of values of if that
every agent receives so we can try and
do the same thing here so we can try and
define the uh the total welfare achieved
by an allocation to be
the sum of the objective values that
every agent receives
but this may not quite be right because
the objective values
might have a very different scale in
this case
so somebody might be valuing click
somebody might be valuing some very
specific actions on their website
and they are not on the same scale
uh the common scale that we were using
earlier was money
uh
and in the quasi-linear setting the bids
that we that represented the values
uh they represented the willingness to
pay
for the bidder
but not in this case right in this case
the willingness to pay
also comes from the constraint so the
objective value does not tell us how
willing or how much they are willing to
pay
so what we're going to do is we're going
to use the cost constraints to infer
their willingness to pay and which is
going to inform the welfare of the
allocation so let's see what we're
actually going to do
uh so this was earlier done by dobsinski
and by slemi
uh in the context of
of of budget constraint bidders
and we and their notion is called liquid
welfare and we're going to extend this
notion to general cost constraints uh so
at a high level we're just going to
define the uh the liquid welfare of a
buyer
as the
for for a particular allocation to be
the their maximum willingness to pay for
that allocation right so we can see
these constraints here so their
willingness to pay
for a particular x i allocation is this
amount taken the minimum over all the
constraints that's the maximum
willingness to be and that is what we'll
call the liquid welfare that this agent
achieves
right and the total liquid welfare is
just the sum over all of these
over all the buyers
so with this definition uh we can now
talk about how bad is the welfare at
equilibrium uh for this we'll use the
concept of price of anarchy which was
defined by um
kutsu pierce and papua demetrius in
1999.
uh it captures how bad the welfare
um of
the of the worst equilibrium can be
compared to the optimal allocation right
so for an instance i you can define uh
opt i
as the maximum welfare over all feasible
outcomes so they don't have to be equal
just feasible outcomes and worst eq of i
is the minimum welfare over all
equilibrium and the price of anarchy is
uh is
is the ratio of opt to worst eq
the the worst over all instances
basically max over of all i of opt i
divided by verse dqi
um so what uh one can show is that
when everybody is using the bidding
formula
and they reach an equilibrium
then the price of anarchy is no more
than two
so this is quite nice because
it is
pretty hard to find equilateral you can
show that finding
the equilibrium is ppad hard
so it is very nice that even though
the equilibrium is very hard to compute
we can characterize
uh it and say that it's no more than two
and in practice it could be much less of
course like the price of energy would be
much less in practice
um
[Music]
again i don't know how much time i have
left um
i can see the chat stream from uh from
the zoom can you
so you can can somebody put in the chat
you if i try to do anything my my slides
go off but i think i can see the chat
stream
um
okay i
five minutes okay great thanks that's
that's perfect um
so i will make sure
yes
um so the final question we look at is
how do reserve prices how do
reserve prices behave under auto bidding
um right so
so first let's take a look at reserve
prices in the quasi-linear setting to
see
how they differ in the auto bidding
setting right so let's assume that the
seller is
selling several items and they're
running a second price auction for each
item and second price auction with
reserve for each item and they're
sitting a uniform reserve for each of
the items and we'll we'll see how
reserve how the change in reserve price
affects welfare and revenue here
the first thing you'll notice that
a second price auction with reserve is
also a truthful option so it is
in the best interest of each buyer to
keep bidding their true value so when a
reserve price changes
the bids actually don't change
and as such it makes it easier to
evaluate different reserve prices and
find an optimal reserve price by kind of
trying out different uh prices
um
another thing hold on one of these lines
are not going
yeah um
the
so another thing to note is that
uh
welfare always goes down as reserve
price goes up this is because
as a reserve price is going up some of
the buyers cannot afford some of the
queries and so those might stay unsold
or maybe in this case since it's uniform
reservation they just stay unsold and so
the total welfare that is um
that is achieved
is lower right the total welfare goes
down uh but the revenue can go up and
down as reserve price
goes up okay so this is this is what
happens in the quasi-linear setting so
let's see what happens in the auto
bidding setting
so here again the seller is selling
multiple items running a second price
auction for each item second price
auction with reserve and the reserve is
uniform across the items
right
so the
the first interesting difference that
happens is that in this case
the bids actually change in response to
the change in the surprise because this
is not a truthful
uh setting so as
uh so the reserve price in some sense
acts like
uh another bidder's bid or it has an
effect on the cost that a bidder is
facing so let's say i increase the
reserve price their cost might go up
they might have a budget constraint and
they have to lower their bid right so
the the bids change when when we change
reserve prices and a new equilibrium is
reached as i mentioned before this
equilibrium is is hard to compute
and because the bids are changing it
also makes it hard to optimize reserve
prices because
if you're trying to try out a new
reserve price
you have to let it settle into an
equilibrium or like have to compute the
equilibrium which as we said is hard
but another interesting thing that
happens is that even welfare can
actually go up as you increase the
reserve price so revenue could always go
up or down as you increase the reserve
price but now welfare can also go
up as reserve price goes up
and i
won't have time to show the full example
but here is the example but i won't go
into the details but the high level idea
is that
uh
the when when we don't have a reserve
one of the buyers can save up some money
on a query that it was buying let's say
it was a budget constrained buyer and it
saved up some money and it can use that
saved up money to buy a query that it
doesn't value very much
uh and that leads to a loss of welfare
because there is a misallocation
whereas if we had used a reserve price
it would not have been able to save that
money on that on one of the queries that
it was winning anyway and then the
second query would have gone to the
right person
all right so
i will probably skip this in the
interest of time
um so i'll conclude uh by saying that
there are lots of new challenges uh that
arise with uh with the increase in auto
bidding opening many exciting new
research directions uh related to
bidding algorithms equilibria
welfare and revenue properties reserve
prices and auction design
in fact one of the things we didn't get
to was auction design like what kind of
alternate per item auctions can we use
and how will they affect welfare and
revenue there's lots of ongoing work
here
another
interesting question is
about
actually designing a truthful mechanism
for this setting so not a per item
mechanism but uh an overall mechanism
that just takes us input these
high-level goals and constraints
outputs and aggregate allocation
and does it in a way that incentivizes
truth telling as as well as performing
well in terms of welfare and revenue
um
so we yeah i will conclude here so thank
you all for uh for your attention i'm
happy to take questions if this time
if somebody can type in the question
that's best because i um
so the question is
sorry so the question is how do you
estimate value
i'm so sorry this is
[Music]
um how to estimate ctr is the solution
to lp sensitive to ctf predictions
uh yeah thanks um
yes so the
yeah so you can estimate ctr by using
historical data
and is it sensitive to so exactly so
that comes back to the question of
uh you know solving it uh on data which
has similar distribution so
it's not super sensitive let's say
because if you get the ctr wrong
by some amount you will
your final value will be wrong by that
amount but it doesn't
uh
yeah i mean so basically the error in
the the predictions will
likely translate to a similar amount of
error in the final value that you
receive
does that answer your question
right can you hear me
yes i can hear you
[Laughter]
yes go ahead i cannot hear you anymore
oh okay well
um uh let's uh thank gagan again
thank you everybody i think i'll
disconnect and reconnect because this
window is behaving pretty badly
very sorry for the technical
difficulties
sorry i'm sorry i'm sure it's on my end
but yeah i'll see you guys soon again
thanks again for giving us a talk even
though you
you are
under the weather
okay so um let's move on to the next
video
now we're setting up just have a very
quick introduction
you met her yesterday so mama currently
is a postdoc research at vmware um
she'll be moving on to technion to be a
faculty member soon and before that she
finished her phd at cmu and won the
dissertation award from the cs
department
also a few best paper awards from
different conferences
so um i guess
her stage of
career is probably closest to you ladies
than any of the other speakers
and i think she was wit participant six
years ago so
um
okay good
um
all right hopefully the clicker works
too um okay so thank you for the
introduction
um
my name is nama then david um i saw i
think all of you yesterday
um
and so like lisa said i'm currently a
researcher at vmware which is why i'm
here in the industry session and i'll be
moving to the technion as an assistant
professor next year in 2023.
um so i just wanted to start by giving a
shout out to women in theory so this is
actually a picture from our industry
session six years ago this is on the
google campus and this is
me over there um so you know speaking at
women in theory means a lot to me i
really enjoyed my time in women in
theory when i came and like i told you
guys at the panel um yesterday i learned
a lot
about you know being
more confident and asking for things and
i think that really helped me in my
career
and another thing that i remember from
when women in theory that i really liked
is that most of the sessions were
technical which i really appreciated
just listening to a lot of
really successful women telling about
their work so i'm happy to contribute to
that too
so having said this this is again my
title slide today i'll talk about
fast and fair lock-free locks and so my
plan for the talk is basically to go
through the title
in reverse order so i'll start by
talking about what locks are and then
what lock freedom is and then we'll work
our way
to fairness and so on
[Music]
so as promised i'll start with locks
so
the setting here is that um we have a
machine that has multiple processes
so you can have multiple threads doing
things and accessing memory at the same
time
and the thing is that so this is called
concurrency right everyone is accessing
memory concurrently and the thing is
that setting can get pretty complicated
right so usually we don't know the
relative speeds of the processes so it
could be that one process is executing
something and another process comes in
in the middle and executes something
really quickly and so on so it's kind of
a messy setting and it's very hard to
reason about
so to ease the design of concurrent
algorithms
locks are generally used okay and in
case you didn't take an operating system
course or you don't remember operating
systems let me just give a very high
level overview of what locks are
so the idea is that
i have some primitive called a lock and
it protects a certain part of memory
and then i could have several processes
that might want to access this memory
and so to do so
they have to grab the lock and the idea
is that the lock at any point in time
has at most one owner
right and so if p1 owns the lock right
now then this means that no one else can
access the memory that the lock protects
okay so p1 now gets exclusive access and
now we can reason about what p1 does
just in the normal sequential setting
um so you know we get this really strong
guarantee where you can execute code
while holding a lock and it executes
atomically or no one else interrupts
your work
um the problem is that we end up getting
bottlenecked by slow processes
right so imagine a situation where p1
now owns the lock
but becomes very slow so it goes to
sleep maybe the operating system
schedules something else on that cpu so
like no proper progress is being made
and if p2 also wanted to access this
lock
it just has to wait right and so we're
really bottlenecked on whatever slow
process now holds the lock
and so to fix this issue
the concept of lock freedom has been
introduced
and the idea is you know we will design
our algorithms so that we will never
block on a slow process
and these algorithms end up being very
intricate we have to reason about
exactly what interleavings could happen
between the different processes
right so the downside is that it's very
complicated to design these algorithms
right and it ends up being that you have
to redesign each algorithm
especially you know for each scenario
right so it's a lot of work and so while
lock freedom is generally very fast and
practical
oftentimes in practice
lock based algorithms are used because
they're just easier to think about
having said this
lock-based algorithms and log-free
algorithms have been
studied a lot in the literature and in
practice and there have been a lot of
data structures designed in both
settings and these are just some sample
ones that are especially uh well known
so the exact citations aren't very
important but notice that there are dot
dots on both sides there are many many
many papers and algorithms on both sides
of this
so that's a good question yeah um so
michael scott is actually a researcher
in the fields however
this
is not just him it's also someone with
the last name michael
so i always think it's unfair that uh
michael scott seems to get the credit
and the funny reference but uh yeah so
it's a very well-known q algorithm in
the field
um okay so but let's recap what these
concepts mean right so we said that
lock-based algorithms you have a lot
where it ensures that some critical code
is run atomically right and lock freedom
what it really means is that we ensure
that no
no process ever blocks us by being slow
right and so if you look at their
definitions and not just the the words
that are used to um to refer to them you
see that they actually don't contradict
each other right and in fact so it could
be the case that the picture is more
like this and there might be some
overlap where we can design
algorithms that have locks but guarantee
lock freedom
and so that's the question you know can
we get simultaneously the simplicity
that locks give us and also the
guarantees of lock freedom and you know
from my title uh you can already guess
that the answer is yes right and so uh
what i'll do in this talk is i'll first
show you how to how we design a
practical
lock-free lock
and then i'll actually talk about
an issue that arises a theoretical issue
that arises from our lock-free lock
construction where the access to the
locks isn't fair and we'll see how to
fix that and i'll just say that this
background picture is supposed to be a
flock of birds because we implemented a
library um for lock free locks
um and we actually called it flock so
that that's the story for the for the
background picture
um okay
so right so we want to have
locks that also give us this lock-free
property that processes don't block
um
okay so you know there's a very simple
idea that kind of comes to mind which is
that if we have a process right and it
wants to grab the lock what it'll do is
first create a descriptor where it just
basically writes down the code that it
would like to run while holding the lock
and it has a pointer from the lock to
the descriptor and once it does that it
can now grab the lock and so if i have
another process come in
now p2 wants to grab the lock
what it can do is it can actually
run p1's code for it
right and so if p2 wants to lock and it
sees that p1 is being slow and it
doesn't want to wait it can just do the
work for p1 and then it can release the
lock itself and put in its own code
so that's a very high level idea of how
we're going to achieve this lock free
property right i don't have to wait for
someone slow i can just do their work
for them they still get their work done
right and i'm happy because i didn't
have to wait
um okay
so
this is the high level idea there is a
problem here though
which is that it's possible that we'll
have several processes running the same
code at the same time
right so it's possible that p2 thought
that p1 was slow but actually p1 was
actively running the code
right and so now both p1 and p2 ran the
code right and we might think maybe
that's not so bad
um but imagine that the code was just an
increment of a
of a value
okay so let's say that we have our
variable var
and its initial value was zero right if
i have both p1 and p2 run the code then
at the end of the day suddenly the
variable's value is two where maybe in
my code
the variable's value should never have
gotten that high right
so we could get into a state that was
illegal originally
so we need to fix this
and so this is this is the main uh
technical challenge for designing log
free locks
so the idea of how to fix it
is that well we want to design code that
when we run it several times it actually
doesn't change the outcome right so it
it looks as if we only ran it once
and this is called item potence and you
might have heard of the word item
potents from linear algebra
right so if you think in linear algebra
if a matrix is item potentials it means
that um
you know multiplying it by itself
uh several times just yields the same
matrix and in our context it means that
an operator applied several times is
like we only applied it once
so this is the effect that we want
except with concurrent code
and i'll just mention that the concept
of you know using designing lock free
locks and needing item potents
was actually proposed in the early 90s
simultaneously by tierracatal and barnes
but their construction was impractical
so they they basically showed how to
take some code not all code but some
classes of code and convert it into
an item-potent piece of code
but it was so slow that it was never
implemented or considered considered
anything that we could really do in
practice
so our main contribution is to show how
to construct item potent code so give me
any piece of code and i'll convert it
into an item piece of code that has the
same effect
in a way that isn't too inefficient
okay so um i'll just briefly outline how
we do this
the idea is that with our descriptor
will not only have our code but also a
log
okay
and what we'll do is that every time i
read the shared memory i'll log the
value that i saw okay so the log will
have
a number of slots corresponding to the
number of reads that i have in my code
so if i want to increment a value right
i want to read that value and then
write that value plus one
you know i'll initialize my log with
some like null value
and then when i read
you know i'll go to uh the variable see
that the value is five and write it into
the log
okay and now after i did that
process p1 can go ahead and write the
new value into
the variable
okay now later if another process the
orange process p2 comes in
and it reads the value
it can go and it can see a six but then
when it goes to the log it sees that the
value is not null but actually something
else
right so now instead of reading the
value six it will adopt the value in the
log
okay and so now p2 even though the value
in on actual memory has changed it will
read the original value
okay and so now p2 when it moves on and
writes the value plus one it will write
the same thing that p1 did
okay so this is the idea we log all the
reads so that all the reads return the
same value for everyone
okay and the concept here is really if
we have some code that's deterministic
and everyone starts in the same states
and all of their reads return the same
value then this means that all of their
rights will do the same as well
okay yeah
can you just express this so
the log doesn't match memory like why i
should just stop at that point
yeah so that's a great question it's so
um the different speeds of the processes
are could actually change over time so
it could be that p1
was fast uh at the beginning you know
was faster than p2 but maybe stopped
right before or right after this right
so in this in this case there's only
like okay we didn't write and p2 sees
that
uh it was written and we're done but
it's possible that there's like a bunch
more code to do and maybe p1 stopped in
the middle right which is why we want to
continue
but good question
um okay so this is the high level idea
yeah so what all information do you need
in your log do you only need um
like i'm wondering how p1 and p2 what
information tells p1 and p2 that they're
executing the same piece of code like it
seems like just having the history of
uh what the variable was like
um right so so notice that in our
descriptor right the log and the piece
of code that you're running are
associated together right so if you want
if you're helping someone else and
you're running a different piece of code
you have a different lock
right so that's why we know sort of by
default that if you're accessing this
log it's referring to the same piece of
code good question
okay so this is a high level idea
and so what we show in our paper is that
you know you can give me any piece of
code
if it's written with just reads and
writes
then i can convert it into an
item-potent piece of code that has the
same effect as the original code and i
add just constant overhead right so the
overhead is now i'm accessing the log on
every instruction instead of just
accessing the memory
right and in fact in our paper
the result was a bit more general so you
could do not just reads and writes but
you can also have compare and swaps
which are atomically allow you to do a
little bit more um and you can also have
allocations and
releases so you can manage your memory
okay but this is the high level idea
[Music]
and so um
now i'll just very briefly show you some
experimental results i know this is a
theory audience but i promise it'll be
quick
um
so like i said we built this library for
lock free locks called flock where you
can basically take a lock and replace it
with a lock free version
and we show that using this library it's
actually very easy to implement lock
free
algorithms
right so
generally log free algorithms there are
entire papers that are devoted to just
design one data structure
and
using this we were able to convert
a lot of data structures
to block free and in fact for this last
one there's a lock based construction
that was relatively complicated and
there was no lock block free solution
until our implementation
and so i'll just very briefly show you
the results for
the linked list data structure which
all the other results kind of look the
same
um so
this is the the experimental results um
what we're seeing here is the dotted
lines are the lock based the blocking
versions and the full lines are lock
free okay and notice that the the blue
and orange lines
we actually took exactly the the lock
based implementations and just plugged
in our library to make them lock free
and the other two
were lock lock-free constructions that
were hand-tuned to be very efficient
and what we're seeing here is on the
y-axis we have throughput so higher is
better and on the x-axis we have more
threads and so what we see is that
the more threads you have in your system
suddenly the the lock-based algorithms
kind of deteriorate when there are a lot
of threads
and with our library we can avoid that
effect
our library is still you know slower
than the very best hand-tuned versions
but it was quite easy to implement so
you know it might be a trade-off that
you would want to make
um so that's it for for the experimental
results yeah
yeah there is so so you see the dotted
line where the sharp thing happens so we
actually ran
um this experiment on a machine with 144
uh
threads
um so it is possible in concurrent
algorithms to spawn more threads than
are physically available on the machine
and so that's what we're doing here and
when you do that what ends up happening
is
it's way more common that a process
takes the lock and then gets
de-scheduled to do something else which
is why the the lock-based ones suddenly
behave way worse
yeah good question
um
okay so that was it for what i wanted to
show you about
this practical item potent
lock-free locks
and now i'll just i just want to point
out a theoretical question that arises
from this and how we can solve it
so let's look again at our basic
construction of how we get this lock
freedom
again if you know we have p1 and it
wants to grab the lock it writes down
its descriptor and takes the lock and
then if p2 wants the lock it has to help
it
right but now imagine that we have a
scenario where while p2 is helping p1
another process p3 comes along
okay and p3 either is faster than p2 and
can help p1 faster
or it actually sees that p2 is done
helping p1
well at this point it can just take over
the lock for itself
right and so now even though p2 already
helped someone
right it can
come in and see that the lock has been
again taken by someone else right and so
now p2 has to help with someone else
and this can can actually continue
forever right so p1 maybe now wants to
do something something new and can take
the lock again
um before p2 has a chance
right so the problem here is that a
process can be blocked forever not by
slow processes but actually by fast
processes right and it never gets its
fair chance at accessing the lock
right and so we want to design an access
algorithm
that will allow everybody a fair chance
of getting the lock for themselves
okay and so to do that i want to just
very briefly give you some more details
on how we model this setting in theory
and what the considerations are
um so in this setting we you know we
want to grab locks but the default state
so there's sort of two states that a
process can be in
the the default one is that the process
doesn't currently want to grab the lock
maybe run some code that doesn't need
locking and then eventually it gets to a
point where it does need the lock
right so by default everyone is this not
wanting a lock state
um and there are transitions right so at
some point some process might say okay
well now i want to grab the lock
at that point it needs to follow the
lock protocol
right and we say that it takes steps so
steps just means that it follows its own
algorithm and we call them steps rather
than i don't know running time or
something like this because the steps
get interleaved with a bunch of other
processes steps and it's hard to really
talk about a notion of time so instead
we talk about a notion of how many steps
did you have to take
um so the idea is while it wants the
lock it follows the lock protocol maybe
other uh processes also join and also
follow the log protocol eventually it
finishes
and it moves back to this default not
wanting the lock state
um now there are sort of um adversaries
that we assume are controlling the
interleaving between uh
the steps right so we assume that
there's some oblivious scheduler
adversary whose job it is to decide at
any point in time of the processes that
are actively wanting the lock and
executing the lock protocol who is going
to take the next step
okay and so basically it controls how
the interleaving works and we assume
that it's oblivious usually because
these interleavings in practice
are affected by things like um
the caches and the operating system and
they're not actually affected by the
values that are being written or
anything that's actively going on in the
execution itself
so we assume that the scheduler doesn't
have access to any of this information
however there's another adversary
which is the adversary that controls
when does a process want to take the
lock when does it sort of enter this
protocol step taking
phase
right and the reason that this adversary
is adaptive is that that is actually
controlled
quite often by the values that the
process has seen during its execution
right it might be that if i read
something then it tells me not to grab
the lock now or i read something else
and it tells me okay you need the lock
right so we assume that we have these
two adversaries the oblivious scheduler
and the adaptive we call it the process
adversary where the process decides when
to enter the
protocol
okay
so with this setting remember our
question is can we design some algorithm
that ensures fair access while
minimizing the number of steps that you
need to take
all right so let's you know try to
design this algorithm and see where
challenges might arise
so you know sort of a
very intuitive idea is to say well what
if i give a random priority
to every uh to every process
right and so when i start uh wanting the
lock
want to grab the lock i'll have some
random priority and if i have the
highest priority of everyone else who's
competing for the lock then i win right
and this would give me a fair chance of
winning as long as the priorities are
chosen um
uh you know in a good
independent way
all right
so for that let's imagine that we have
some set
of a bunch of descriptors with their
priorities
right and so if i have p2 and it wants
to grab the lock what it'll do is it
will create its descriptor and choose a
random priority
and then it will add itself to the set
and then it'll compare see if its
priority is the highest of everyone
and if so it wins and otherwise
it will help the winner to make sure
that it doesn't have to encounter that
winner again if it ends up trying again
okay
and you know if you lost then you can
just restart this process get a new
random priority and if you want them
great
so there's actually a problem with this
approach
and the problem is that remember the
choice of when i actually start this
protocol is controlled by an adaptive
adversary
and in particular this adaptive
adversary can wait and see what the
priorities are of the of the processes
who are already participating
and if it wants to be mean to p2
what it can do is actually wait until it
sees that there's someone with a very
high priority
and then schedule p2 to start knowing
that there's a lower chance that it will
win
there's a fairly low chance that it'll
get a random priority that's highest
than this very high value
right so this is a problem right and in
fact
an adversary can make uh
p2 do arbitrarily badly
okay so we want to fix this so let's uh
you know take a look at this algorithm
and see what we can do
so the solution that we have is actually
quite similar and the only changes that
we make is these um
green changes
okay so the idea is instead of right
away picking your priority
you're going to start the protocol
without any priority okay so
um when you want to grab the lock
you enter the tournament with your
descriptor with with a blank priority
um and
what you'll do is actually do this
helping thing so you'll check who has
the highest priority and you'll help
that person complete and you'll notify
the others that they lost and so on
before you're even competing before you
have a priority and so what we get here
is that the competitors that were
present when p2 joined are no longer
present
later on when p2 competes by itself
and in the meantime it's possible that
others have joined and maybe they
already have their priorities
and eventually once
p2 has cleared all the competitors that
were there when it entered
then it chooses its own priority and
does the same thing where if it's the
highest priority it wins and if not it
will try again okay so note the the nice
thing here
is that
when the adversary chooses to let p5 p2
enter
it has no information about the
priorities that p2 will actually have to
compete with right all of the priorities
that were already there
are by processes that will not cause p2
to to fail
right so p2 will help them and clear
them from the competition and only then
will it compete so we weaken the power
that the adaptive adversary had over us
okay so that's the main intuition
um in our paper we show that this really
works so if you think of k as the
maximum number of competitors that we
can have at any point in time
we show that this algorithm achieves
this lock free lock property
where it gives everyone a chance of at
least one over k to succeed at any
in any attempt
and each attempt takes um about
k squared steps
can you explain a little bit about that
yeah so
so the problem is that we need to um
figure out how to break ties
in a reasonable way and you could say
okay well maybe i can
cue everybody up right and i can just
let them succeed
um sort of in the order that they can
came in
but intuitively what that does is it
shifts the problem from um
the lock to the queue now the question
is how can i design an algorithm that
lets everybody queue
in a fair way
right so because of the concurrency it's
possible that maybe p2 wanted to take
the next slot in the queue but someone
else came in and grabbed it right and
now p2 has to take the spot after that
and so on so we're kind of we we're
keeping the same problem but shifting it
and so it's actually it's
unclear how you would be able to do this
deterministically um and we have reason
to believe that it's impossible but i'll
talk i'll be happy to talk about that
offline
um okay so that's the general results in
our paper we actually extend this to
being able to grab multiple locks at a
time
um
okay
but that's all i wanted to show you
so i'll just very briefly conclude
um so i showed you sort of two parts
right one is
we showed that if we have the ability to
design item potent code then we can have
these lock free locks
and we show we showed that using this um
descriptor log
um then you can get item potentials in a
fairly
efficient manner
and then we also have this priority
based algorithms to ensure fairness fair
access to the lock
right and that
to get that right we had to time
the um priority picking or revealing
time to avoid the adversarial effects
um and i'll just leave you with a couple
of future directions
i showed this item points construction
and i said it's efficient and i showed
this fair access algorithm and in the
title i said that it's fast but it's
quite possible that we can design better
item potency constructions and a faster
fair access algorithm
so that would be very interesting and
the other thing is that we did assume an
oblivious scheduler adversary
that does some have some effects that we
had to mitigate in the actual algorithm
that i swept under the rug
um and you know i gave you sort of
practical motivation for why it makes
sense that it would be oblivious
but it's also interesting to ask well
can we design an algorithm that would
work against an adaptive scheduler
adversary and we don't actually have an
answer to that so our algorithm would
not work against an adaptive adversary
um and with that oh thank you for your
time
um maybe one one quick question somebody
try to repeat once the code of one
process it's not trading any overhead
even though
yeah so it is true that um and this goes
back to sort of the idol's construction
right it's true that if i have many
processes it could be that all of them
are kind of wasting their time by
finding the same piece of code
and um i think that's an unavoidable
part of
this concurrency setting
and if you want to have more freedom
it could be a good question of in
practice can we have some flag that says
you know if someone finished it i can
raise a flag and then everybody else can
stop or something like this so it does
waste um some work
um and so it's a trade-off right in some
cases where locks are fine and there
isn't too much contention
it might be better to just use a lock
that doesn't have everybody repeating
the same code
um
thank you
so
[Music]
last but not least we'll have shipra
from google research
who will be telling us about
auctions and advertising so shepard and
did her phd at stanford
in algorithmic game theory under tim
rathgarden so before this talk actually
we were comparing notes of uh path you
know both finishing
high school in a foreign country and
coming to the us
we were 17-18 to the undergraduate here
and did phd and end up
working for industry research labs so
it's very interesting so i look forward
to
your talk thank you yeah
so yeah i was actually a student at
women in theory the first time it
happened which was in 2008 i was about
to start phd
and i really valued it as an experience
at that time and it sort of gave me
uh exposure to many awesome women from
diverse research areas from theoretical
cs so whenever i went to like stockholm
soda
i knew lots of people which is always a
bit daunting when you're a woman so i
appreciate that it's great that you know
all this thing has kept going for so
many years
uh so today i'm going to talk about uh
simple mechanisms for rich advertising
auctions this is joint work with
gaga nagarwal and arnic mehta from
google and alex somas from purdue and
divyarti mohan from tel aviv university
we've seen this screenshot and guidance
talk but so the sponsored search options
which are options for ads that are shown
next to your search results on say
google or bing
they look very different now than they
used to 10 years ago
so 10 years ago these were just position
options for text ads so each ad was just
a headline url and two lines two three
lines of text
all ads were of the same height
and uh every advertiser used to provide
only a single ad
so it was a simple just like select the
top k
uh problem
but nowadays we have the flexibility to
show bigger or smaller ads with
different amounts of details so the same
advertiser might provide multiple ads
and then we are trying to find the best
set of ads to show
and to sort of illustrate this point
further here's sort of a sample of
different kinds of ads that can show up
for a query like rental cars
i know the text is a bit small to read
but like they're just ads from different
advertisers
and uh
you can kind of also see the kinds of
details they have they might have site
links taking you deeper within the
website there might be a link to
download their app there might be a
rating that tells you how sort of how
reliable the merchant is there can be
offers to kind of convince you to click
on their ads
so all of these details affect the
probability of click for that ad
it also affects the amount of space this
ad takes up on the page
but we still have
the limited amount of space in which we
can show ads because we don't want to
overwhelm the user with ads
so then we encounter a packing problem
so what is the best set of ads that we
can show in this space
and for sort of like this economic
setting we're going
for this talk in particular we're going
to focus on social welfare as the
objective to measure how a good a set of
ads
addresses
and in the sponsored search option
setting
advertisers normally specify a value per
click
and then the probability of a click on
the ad can be learned using a machine
learning model so the social welfare is
some overall advertisers of their value
per click times the probability of click
which is kind of like the total value
that everybody gets out of the
allocation
and then we have constraints we have a
knapsack constraint that says that the
ads must fit within the available space
and we're only allowed to show one ad
per advertiser because it wouldn't give
users good value if we were repeating
the same ad from expedia twice with
slightly different formats
but there is additional complexity the
inputs to this algorithm are provided by
strategic agents which are the
advertisers
so advertisers might have their own
intrinsic value per click
and then the set of rich ads that they
want to show which is kind of like what
are they trying to
market to the users at
any given point
but if we don't design our auction
carefully they might misreport some of
this they might report a different bid
or only report a subset of the ads to
kind of make sure that we give them
exactly what they want and nothing else
and in particular we'll assume that the
advertisers have quasi-linear utility so
they're trying to maximize
their value minus the cost and in the
sponsored search setting
the cost is usually represented as a
cost per click so the utility is
probability of clicks times or expected
clicks times value minus the cost per
click
and as i said advertisers will misreport
their bids and recharge
to maximize this utility
so we want to design a truthful option
which gives us a guarantee that the
advertiser will maximize the utility if
they just give us their true preferences
they'll report their true value and set
of rich ads
and this is a dominate dominant strategy
for them so no matter what anybody else
is doing they can just support their
true value and be assured that this will
give them the best utility
the main result in our theorem is we in
our paper is we provide a truthful
auction that provides a free
approximation to the optimal social
welfare
and the bench work benchmark that we're
competing here is optimal social welfare
assuming truthful reporting
um and in fact actually we are competing
against the fractional optimal which
i'll talk about more later
and there are two reasons for
approximation here one is computational
because the problem is np heard
and the second is truthfulness to align
sort of the advertiser's expectations
with the or doctrine you want to
maximize we have to also give up a
little bit on the
approximation
the area of richards is actually very
rich and sort of as
internet advertising has evolved various
teams have come up with different models
that capture some aspect of it and so
there's bunch of works from different
industry groups uh
related to this
uh the first couple are actually looking
at sort of the computational problem
where we can't solve the optimal problem
how how how should we approximate it
what kind of incentive and approximation
guarantees can we provide
and then the second group is actually
dealing with
uh this property so richards is actually
a special case of combinatorial options
which is a much more general model
and in combinatorial auctions
uh classic options like vcg and all do
not provide core allocations
which kind of
briefly basically means that
we could add more competition to an
auction and make less revenue which is a
very contentive and hopefully wouldn't
happen but can happen so the latter two
papers are trying to deal with that uh
while sort of
assuming good competition is available
and things like that but those are
definitely couple of interesting
research agendas in this uh area
so now let's get dive into sort of the
technical details so what is our
algorithm and how do we do it so let's
first understand the benchmark which is
the optimal social welfare without
incentives
so we can write it as an integer program
relax it to an ip and it's a fairly
simple program we have a knapsack
constraint and then we have these
additional constraints of only one ad
per advertiser
this problem is actually np hard
which is not surprising because it's
knapsack plus added constraints
but just like maps uh
so so the main difference from knapsack
is so we have items which have value and
size but they're grouped together
and then we have a constraint that
within each group we're only allowed to
pick one item from each group
and so that gives a slightly different
allocation than we would if we didn't
have
this group constraint
but just like in the case of knapsack
even this problem we can solve using a
simple
so even the fractional optimization of
this problem we can solve using a simple
greedy algorithm
so this is a result by cinna and
zoltners from 76
um we actually proved it ourselves and
realized too late that it was already
well known so there is a lesson there of
like doing your literature search um
but so the idea is that we should
allocate in the incremental bank for
recorder so for knapsack normally we are
located in the bank but work order
here because we have a constraint of
only one
ad or item per group
whenever we add another item from that
group we have to remove the previous one
so we have to consider sort of the what
is the incremental value of adding this
item divided by the incremental space
that it will take
so in that sense like if all the items
were
very well sorted in terms of value and
size
then you could just reduce this to
knapsack and then solve the knapsack
problem
in reality they might not be well sorted
there can be other items which are
higher value lower size and things like
that but those will be dominated the
optimal solution won't use them
and so then sort of the
first step for the reduction is just
saying like there are these items which
no the optimal solution don't you won't
use let's get rid of them and now we can
reduce it in knapsack
and so that gives us the fractional
optimal
uh
here let's also have an example to just
illustrate what this incremental bank
per buck means
so um for the first item from a group
there's nothing that has been placed
before so the incremental bank per buck
is just the bank per buck
for any subsequent item
we compute the incremental bank per book
as sort of the incremental value over
the previously placed item divided by
the incremental size so you can think of
it as just break taking the large item
and breaking it up into two smaller
pieces
and sort of thinking of them
individually
and when there are multiple items in a
group we sort of do it consecutively so
any two consecutive values will sort of
uh consider the incremental piece for
each subsequent one
and so here's sort of a sample run
of the incremental bank per work
algorithm
and so it will just keep adding items
and whenever the next item in the
incremental banker book is from a group
that's already placed like the 18 and 21
value one gray items here then we'll
just replace the previous one
and then finally we'll get to a stage
where the next item that we want to
place is too big for the remaining space
available so that's where we added
fractionally but we won't just add this
item fractionally but we will still
steal space
from a previous item from the same group
so like in this example the 21 value
item was already added we take a little
bit of space from the 21 and give it to
this 30 item to sort of optimize
within the available space between these
two items that are available
but the nice thing about this is that
the
optimal fractional solution is mostly
integer
except for this one group where there
are two items that we are fractionally
allocating in between every other item
is allocated integrally
and this also gives us a two
approximation algorithm which is also
similar to like well what we have for
knapsack
so if we just take the allocation before
we added the last item
and the last item and then pick the
larger of these two
that actually covers the fractional
solution
and so it gives us a two approximation
so there is a simple two approximation
algorithm
for multi-choice snapshot
but this was without any kind of auction
design consideration so now let's go
back to truthful mechanism how are we
going to do that
there are two common truthful hammers
that are used in algorithm theory one is
the weekly cloud growth mechanism other
is myerson's lemma
so which of these can we use
so the wikri glarg gross mechanism is a
really strong result pretty awesome it's
pretty general it can be used in
multi-parameter settings
and all it says is that you should solve
the optimal problem
and then charge to each advertiser or
each uh participant
in the winning solution
their externality sort of what damage
are they doing to everybody else
and that externality can be calculated
by just solving the optimization problem
without this participant
and then subtracting from that what
everybody else is getting in the optimal
allocation
so it's sort of very simple and very
clean
and this is truthful and the
truthfulness sort of follows from the
fact that we are solving the
optimization problem optimally
so it kind of aligns the advertiser's
incentives with the auctioneer's
incentives
but it's not computationally feasible
it requires us to solve the
computational problem
n plus one times basically
um and there are some extensions so this
is sort of a common problem that's
encountered in combinatorial auctions in
general
and there are some extensions in some
special cases
where we can still use this template
with an approximation algorithm to
provide it with full option but it's not
sort of a general hammer in that sense
[Laughter]
so yeah so so basically like we don't
know how to do this in this setting
question yeah just to clarify
um if there are settings
mechanisms
actually even sort of like
just a simple sponsored search option
setting like the position auction
setting
um
yeah they think the second price like
the good footprint is no longer simple
in fact there we cannot say like oh
actually it's not too bad because like
the bias and interpretation would be
hard but look at the vct interpretation
it's so easy but um but it's out of
reduces like this is the simplest we can
describe the cgs like solve the optimal
problem n plus one times
so the second hammer is myosin so this
is a very classic and awesome result by
merson
it says that in a single parameter
setting so if every participant is just
giving us one value then a truthful
auction is equivalent to having a
monotone allocation rule so if somebody
bids higher they get allocated more
and then that can be paired with a
unique payment rule which is just some
integral based on sort of the allocation
rule
and that option is truthful
and sort of the payment rule actually
also has a nice interpretation that also
gives us like some like pictorial proofs
for why this is truthful so the payment
is just this area above the curve
for the allocation so so in the picture
here the curve is sort of showing the
allocation rule so as the advertiser or
as a participant raises their bid
they'll get more and more
and the payment is this area about the
curve that's shaded
but this is for single parameter
so what we do here what we're trying to
do here is actually still use the same
formula
but not it doesn't follow directly from
the lemma but we can follow the same
steps
so we will try to design an algorithm
that is monotone in value per click and
a set of rich ads
and in the case of set of rich ads it's
like it's a set so it's more of like a
set so like if you give a subset of ads
you get less if you get a super set of
ads you get more kind of monotonicity
and then we can pair it with meiosis
like payment rule
and prove that the resulting
auction would be truthful
and uh
so there's like a small lemma here to
prove that like this combination works
out and this is similar to uh what has
been done in recent years in some of
these one and a half dimensional revenue
maximization papers where they similarly
have a multi-parameter setting with
multiple dimensions being controlled but
one of the dimensions is non-monetary
and then they prove similar results
saying like let's give a moment to an
allocation rule pair it with myosin like
payment rule and that becomes structured
so that reduces our problem to just
designing monotone allocation algorithms
and so we have to prove that that the
participant won't be able to
gain uh
more by sort of reporting a lower value
or reporting a subset of ads
in individually we don't have to do the
together part the together part is
already done in the
lemma
so what are uh what is a good monotonous
algorithm
so we find that a lot of the standard
algorithms that we might use in this
allocation are not monotone
so one is just like comparing set of ads
so maybe we somehow come up with like
some different ways of putting the ads
together
and now let's just compare the two and
pick whichever is the higher
turns out that's normal return so in
this simple example where this is the
universe of ads
if the grade advertiser removes the
smaller ad
that's going to force our algorithm to
pick this larger ad sticks larger single
ad and so they can get higher bigger
allocation by reporting subset of their
ads
and in fact the same example also shows
that the integer opt if it was somehow
computationally retractable is not
monotone because that's exactly what
we're doing in integer opt
then the second thing is maybe the
incremental bank per work algorithm that
we use for the
approximating the fraction knob maybe
that is monotone
turns out
that's also not monotone
so uh this uh the allocation on the
right is sort of what we get if
everybody's reporting truthfully
now let's suppose that the
blue advertiser removes their smaller ad
now their bigger ad which earlier had
small incremental bank per buck
now we just consider the bank per buck
for it which is higher so it gets to be
allocated sooner
and so in the resulting allocation
the blue advertiser gets a bigger ad and
more allocation so they're better off
so so that doesn't work
but
not all yeah
yeah so more space well so
there can be like i guess you're
considering the general model where more
space may not always mean more included
yeah um
so they what they really want is more
tree today
but if there were things where like more
space does not mean more click-through
rate then we should just remove those
like more avocados
so they don't want to maximize their
backbone
yeah they want to just maximize their
value which is the value for the click
thanks to including
which is sort of like the numbers
written here are just those like
combined quantity
so here's a simple algorithm which is
monotone just allocate to the highest
value if there is space remaining keep
going
that is clearly monotone like bit higher
you get more
if you remove something it doesn't
matter because whatever like the highest
value one that you are getting that's
still there
um the problem is this can be
this can lead to very poor approximation
there might just be a massive ad which
just happens to have a lot of value we
place that it blocks all the space
nothing else can be packed and this can
be like infinitely bad in the worst case
there's another algorithm which is
monotone which is to allocate in the
bang for the order so this is like the
algorithm we had for knapsack um it
makes a comeback and
it is monotone
so sort of the high level intuitive idea
is the bank purporter is kind of
independent of what else is present like
if you remove some subset of your ads
doesn't matter the rest of the ads are
unaffected
there is a little bit of caveat there
which is that
the bank per book order is kind of not
absolute sometimes there might be a
lower bank per work ad which is also
lower value
in which case we don't want to allocate
it
so there is a little bit of care
required in the proof to kind of
think about all the possible cases and
argue that in each of those cases nobody
will be able to gain by reporting a
subset of their ads
but it can be done we can prove that
this is monotone
and so
here's like a sample run of the bank per
buck algorithm
where now uh so the gray ad
gets a much bigger allocation in the
bank work order
and we end up stopping early because the
next ad that we would have considered in
this order which will be the pink ad
cannot fit within the remaining space
so
already in this picture it looks like
it's not
as good as the sort of the fractional
opt or the integer we could come up with
but maybe it's a good approximation
turns out still not you can consider a
very bad example like if you have seen
the bad example for knapsack where bank
per book fails it's similar the same
example works so
of course this is not by itself is not
good but maybe some combination of the
bank per buck and highest value that
could work
so that's a theorem that we proved that
allocating in the banquet book order
with probability two-thirds and picking
a single highest ad with probability
one-third
will give us a three approximation to
the fractional opt and it will also be
monotonous
note here that we are randomizing
between those two locations we are not
picking the higher of the two which is
kind of what we do for the approximation
algorithm
and that's mainly because of
monotonicity because again otherwise
that'll like as i showed in the example
it breaks
and uh interestingly this is another
approximation algorithm for multi-choice
snapsack it's slightly worse than the
two approximation i proved earlier
but like from a practical perspective
it's kind of nice like if you didn't
know about multi-choice knapsack you
just use the knapsacks algorithm you
wouldn't be too worse off
um and this analysis is tight there we
have an example which where you cannot
do better than a three approximation in
that example with this
construction
thanks
all right so then we have a monotone
allocation rule it can be paired with
myosins like payment rules and we'll get
a truthful option
so now let's switch gears slightly and
talk about gsp
so in the sponsorship setting due to
various historical reasons we don't
implement the truthful option like vcg
or meyerson's like payment rules
and the story was kind of very simple we
know for a single item second price is
truthful
so then when they were going to multiple
slots they just said like let's continue
second price
and it took a paper bagger gun actually
to show that no that's not truthful
anymore
uh and halo varian also had a similar
paper around the same time but the main
difference for gsp compared to myerson
is that when you have like a step
function allocation where as you bid
higher you get higher and higher on the
page or get bigger and bigger allocation
meyerson says we should charge the area
under the curve so sort of like for each
step in click-through rate like charge a
higher price only for those incremental
clicks while gsp says let's charge the
high price to all of your clips
and
that so that so we're charging a lot
more than we would with the truthful
payment rule
and that creates an incentive for the
participants to lower their bid to get a
better trade-off between the value
they're getting and the cost they're
paying
so gsp is not truthful
uh and even in this rich ad setting
where now we have a monotone allocation
rule so we could sort of define a
similar payment rule which is just sort
of like let's find a threshold where you
start losing clicks
that is also not going to be truthful
so what can we say about sort of the
social welfare that we get in this
well we can use price of anarchy
so price of anarchy is a very nice
solution concept introduced in one of
the major contribution of the algorithm
the game theory community introduced by
kusupius and papua dmitry in 99 and it
has been studied in various models like
condition games auctions social networks
so it's like a popular metric for us
so what we do is because the auction is
not truthful we can't just focus on the
settings where everybody's just bidding
their true value so we look at a nash
equilibrium where everybody is still
maximizing their utility assuming
everybody else is just bidding whatever
they are bidding so i want to best
respond to whatever everybody else is
doing
there can be many such nash equilibrium
so for to measure the price of energy i
want to look at the worst case so what
is the worst case approximation a nash
equilibrium can have compared to the
social optimal
and the same
metric can be extended to more general
equilibrium concepts like mixed
correlated or bayes nash and bayes nash
in particular is
perhaps the more relevant one in an
auction setting because
the participants have values on from
distribution and the base nash kind of
captures that
so we proved that the pure nash price of
anarchy in this setting is about six
so we are still doing like the bank per
buck allocation pairing it with
gsp payment the highest value allocation
pairing it with jsp payment we're
picking between these two with some
probability we use it half half here
instead of the two third one third
before
and we show that this has a price of
energy of six
and this can be extended to more general
solution concept like mix and base nash
using smoothness which is this general
hammer
that was proposed by of guardian and
extended by circumstant tardis to
various settings
and our proof in particular follows a
template from uh kara ganasetta where
they approved price of anarchy bounds
for the gsp auction in the position
auction setting
and so sort of like once you have the
pure price of nrt proof
uh the smooth with the smoothness
framework it you can easily extend it to
more general solution concepts
so
there's lots of interesting open
questions that can be solved in this
recharge advertising options domain
there's definitely open questions
related to some of the related works i
cited earlier
for the model in particular that we
study i think in terms of designing
truth reductions we're just getting
started
in real-world auctions we have position
effects so if your ad is shown higher on
the page you will get a higher
click-through rate and our model right
now is not capturing that there can
there is usually also a number of ads
constraints like we want to only show
four ads
and we are not capturing that right now
and then the second thing is uh like how
to maximize revenue in this setting is
also not very understood because now the
advertisers are specifying a value per
click and a set of ads this is no longer
a single parameter domain
so we cannot use all the standard
machinery
it might not be as hard as sort of like
some of the
like multi-item uh combinatorial auction
kind of settings that have been studying
which have proven hard
uh but um so it's something more like
the one and a half dimensional setting
perhaps but there's still work to be
done to figure out the details of it
and thank you and we have our paper on
archive if anybody wants to look at it
[Applause]
so you mentioned that the algorithm
analysis
but
is the problem generally hardly
strongly and you are i mean
is
uh also the other thing is uh so you
mentioned the settings where each
application has a bunch of options
uh if we remove this constraint is it
going to make the problems here
yes so if if each advertiser just has a
single ad yeah but it can be of
different sizes
then it doesn't become a multi-parameter
problem anymore
uh
you it will still be computationally
hard
but i think in that case we could use a
betas because like the monotonicity is
harder because of this
uh set function like uh getting
monotonously in the bed is currently
easy
so right
there itself maybe something could be
done but we don't know how to do it
uh and then even within myers and maybe
there's other ways of approaching it
one more question so um what i
understand is you're assuming that
it doesn't matter like
where the ads are placed like as long as
it's there but um
if that if there's a supporter like it
is a diminishing value to very position
the ad
and then maybe there's no limit but some
thing like a diminishing value
yes yeah so um so the position
multiplier is kind of capturing that
right so you could say like there is k
but like there's an exponential drop off
like if you're the k narration then you
have like exponential base or position
multiplier so that would be one model
and we don't know how to talk right
another actually interesting option
aspect is that even the position
multipliers might not be the right so
what matters for your click-through rate
might not be how many ads are above you
but how much space is occupied about you
so your click-through rate should be a
function of how much space is occupied
above you and your size
and yeah we don't want to do that
all right so let's uh thank shifa again
okay
in the schedule you might remember that
we had planned for a 30-minute industry
panel but we're not going to have it
anymore because when we planned it we
didn't know the industry speakers would
be with us for the main panel yesterday
so so this actually is the end of the
sort of the intellectual part of the
workshop and the last organized event is
lunch outside and after that
we are done and then i know you all have
travel plans and and all that so so safe
travel home
and uh we should stay in touch with
email we want to post everybody's um
emails hopefully you know long-term
email not the one that you have with
your current institution so we can all
stay in touch and cetera so do let me
know
personally if you have comments concerns
suggestions you can put it in the
survey we it's completely anonymous we
don't know who
who writes it who wrote it so but it's
so wonderful to have you here it's my
first event since pandemic
so
so it's really wonderful so enjoy the
lunch it's outside
okay shibanki is not here either so
we're thinking you know the uh
so with all the help and you you girls
are so wonderful next time perhaps we
can have a workshop without any
organized person
so you can just do it all by yourself